美味しい
さあ
goo
[音楽]
tj
ファー五飛 ri 3 u 2組買ってまいりましたつけましょう
とアメリカから届いただからネットでは耐えられたら知ってる人も多いと思うんです
けども
うん
こんな
すー
夏時間すーっはーっ
はぁんっ
しかしかもっ
うわぁあああっっっ
袋から開けますすー
スゥーと
[音楽]
ございまーす
はっはっは世界最大級の巨大組
ファーム組っていうのかな日本虫みたいな形の巨大なグミを買ってきました
精勤さんもやってたかなじゃバイこれマジでっていうかこれ組やはいで
ビルに耐えないサイズなんですけどもう
こっちは保存しようニコアプリがこっちは冷蔵庫いうと一つじゃないっていうのは今日
はこちらの世界最大級の葉含みを一人でくれます
何の4000キロカロリーぐらいか何かそういう話もあるんですけども
俺はこういう音これぐらい女帝キュッ
この巨大俵に今から来いますいただきます
[音楽]
持ってん
ん
はい
俺のねちょっと俺はなんかね扇できないんだよイメージなってるけどそんなことはない
からねやる時はやるそれがこの俺
[音楽]
味はねちょっポンッとぽいかな
ちょっとこいつぁないです
お前
ガーンん
なんか
エロいねこれマルコ都5県でどんなば全部食われる中入って4月んですよね
5 a
[拍手]
[音楽]
まだ意見
まだいっちゃん
me
落ち着けばないけどあーこりゃこりゃヴァイは思ってちゃの時は
グミーと思ったんですけど海じゃねこれ組じゃないよ
何かお菓子には思っての措置は丸バエ
ジェルぞ
てろハイウェイ
あああああ
ザーッ細くなっている
[音楽]
amazon とかに疑ってると思うんでぜひよかったらチャレンジしてみてください
1リーチャー無理だと思うんでみんなでやろうね